globalement je vais dire par rapport à
des collègues qui sont tout simplement
je vais être très très dur décédé
d'autres qui sont dans des lits
aujourd'hui qui ne peuvent plus bouger
comme moi j'ai la chance de pouvoir
justement parler je veux parler à leur
nom quoi
bonsoir
agriculteurs j'ai été empoisonné par des
pesticides que vous utilisez et
aujourd'hui vous devriez être mort
mais je suis bien vivant et bien vivant
mais bien malade quand même puis des
dégâts collatéraux par rapport à cet
empoisonnement au niveau neurologique
néphrologique et immunitaire quand on
voit ce que vous êtes arrivé et que nous
on mange tout ça ça
ça fait peur on parle justement souvent
du consommateur et de l'environnement
les premières victimes ça va être nous
les agriculteurs on en reparle à 20h
vous êtes né en 1964 à Ruffec en
Charente vos parents étaient
agriculteurs en 1982 vous passez un BEP
agricole et 5 ans plus tard vous avez 23
ans vous vous installez à votre compte
sur la ferme familiale en Charente
dès les premières années vous appliquez
ce que vous avez appris dans les écoles
d'agriculture c'est à dire l'utilisation
massive d'engrais et de pesticides et ça
marche ça fonctionne très très bien
votre exploitation passe de 27 à 200
hectares donc vous gagnez de l'argent
oui puis à l'époque
toutes ces chimie nous permet
d'augmenter les revenus nous permet
d'augmenter les rendements ça répond à
l'attente aussi du de la société qui
veut une indépendance alimentaire au
niveau de la France et voir aussi en
Europe donc tout le monde y retrouve son
compte moi j'ai j'ai vu mon père
travailler péniblement dans les champs
la chimie nous permettait de travailler
avec moins d'efforts physiques et donc
c'est formidable quoi vous dites
d'ailleurs je suis le pur produit de
l'agriculture intensive complètement
complètement je l'ai pratiqué je n'en
suis pas fier mais je n'en ai pas honte
non plus mais dans les années 90 les
prix commencent à stagner et pour
maintenir les rendements vous êtes
obligé d'utiliser des quantités de plus
en plus importantes de
produits chimiques qui dit produit
chimique dit protection les pouvoirs
publics vous incitent évidemment à vous
protéger de la tête aux pieds
effectivement pour l'image de vos
produits c'est difficile d'être vu dans
un champ habillé comme si vous
travaillez dans une centrale nucléaire
quoi c'est exactement ça le discours
officiel protégez-vous et le discours
officieux dire attention si tout le
monde vous voit traiter avec des tenues
de cosmonaute qui va acheter ces
produits moi je me protéger les mains et
le visage mais les tenues je
reconnaissent pas forcément non et un
jour tout bascule c'est le 27 avril 2004
en ouvrant le couvercle d'une cuve de
produits chimiques vos voies
respiratoires sont envahies par une
puissante odeur et à ce moment-là une
une bouffée de chaleur qui est inhalée
un produit qui était devenu un gaz en
fin de compte parce que dans cette cuve
il faisait très chaud et le produit
était devenu un gaz vous rentrez chez
vous en titubant là vous prenez une
douche et la suite vous vous en souvenez
pas c'est-à-dire vous avez cinq jours
d'amnésie quand même la suite je m'en
souviens pas j'ai eu la chance mon
épouse était professionnel de la santé a
eu les bons réflexes tu en difficulté
respiratoire donc je fais que répéter ce
qui m'a été expliqué et j'ai repris mes
esprits 5-6 jours après à l'hôpital le
diagnostic c'est intoxication au
monochloro benzène la molécule qui entre
dans la composition du désherbant que
vous utilisez mais le centre antipoison
est assez optimiste on vous dit il y a
pas de souci à se faire tout va rentrer
dans l'ordre le centre antipoisement ne
faites pas de traitement particulier ni
d'analyse surtout c'est ce qui est le
plus grand scandale tout va rentrer dans
l'ordre quelques semaines tout tout sera
comme avant c'est pas du tout passé
comme ça pas du tout alors vous vous
reprenez votre travail exactement dans
les mêmes conditions que que
précédemment les fin 2004 votre état de
santé s'aggrave vous vous bégayez vous
perdez le fil de vos pensées vous
devenez irritable oui complètement vous
avez maigri j'étais très fatigué j'avais
et j'avais surtout des pertes de
connaissances et des maux de tête qui
devenaient de plus en plus violents
jusque j'ai été hospitalisé suite à des
maux de tête pour une suspicion
méningite ménagée pardon et donc et à
partir de là j'ai été suivi de service
balader de service en service le centre
anti-poison dit c'est impossible que le
chlorobenzen puisse générer de tels six
mois après son intoxication donc il y a
pas besoin de faire de prise de sang il
y a pas besoin de faire d'analyses
d'urine c'est incroyable et ce qui est
moi m'a toujours surpris c'est qu'à
chaque fois que je perds des
connaissances dans on me faisait des
prélèvements pour voir si on retrouvait
pas des médicaments de l'alcool du tabac
des psychotropes et j'en passe mais
jamais on essayait de rechercher s'il y
avait un toxique quelconque pouvant
avoir un lien avec mon intoxication
alors certains toubib en arrivent même à
vous persuader que vous êtes dépressif
vous retrouvez dans une hôpital
psychiatrique vous prenez des
antidépresseurs mais vous multipliez les
communes à ce moment-là j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer des
qui ont très bien fait leur travail qui
ont dit Monsieur François est
certainement dépressif parce que malade
mais pas malade parce qu'il est
dépressif ce qui est fondamentalement
différent et heureusement qu'ils sont
intervenus parce que je pense que
j'aurais fini complètement shooté par
les médicaments alors finalement ça
n'est qu'en février 2005 donc
pratiquement un an après la votre
intoxication qu'on vous fait une prise
de sang incroyable et la stupeur on
détecte du chlorofénole en grande
quantité oui et les gens ils croient pas
il y a un toubib qui dit à votre femme
votre mari se shoote au désherbant il y
en a un autre qui lui dit le produit
avec lequel vous teniez les cheveux
finalement il est plus dangereux que que
ce qu'il a voilà c'était alors c'était
très dur à vivre vous avez la chance de
rencontrer Henri peserin qui vous fait
un traitement à base d'algues le même
qui a été fait au président
ukrainien Victor huxchenko aujourd'hui
vous souffrez d'amnésie d'insuffisance
respiratoire vertige d'absence mais
surtout vous avez un déficit immunitaire
très grave ce qui fait que vous preniez
pratiquement des des antib boutique les
trois quarts de l'année on sait pas trop
parce que les médecins cherchent encore
mais c'est vrai que je ne voyais que mon
médecin pour prendre l'apéro avant
excusez-moi mais jamais pour me soigner
et depuis bah voilà j'ai que des
problèmes de santé alors
globalement je vais dire par rapport à
des collègues qui sont tout simplement
je vais être très très dur décédé
d'autres qui sont dans des lits
aujourd'hui qui ne peuvent plus bouger
comme moi j'ai la chance de pouvoir
justement parler je veux parler à leur
nom quoi parce oui à partir de là vous
menez un combat judiciaire contre la
mutuelle parce que la mutuelle refuse de
vous indemniser au-delà de 5 semaines
ils vous disent vous allez mieux
pourquoi vous voulez absolument savoir
ce qui s'est passé vous allez mieux
maintenant tout est rentré dans l'ordre
qui vous avez été vous avez passé 9 mois
dans les hôpitaux mais pourquoi vous
vous posez des questions par rapport aux
produits vous n'avez pas nous embêter
quelque part alors la fnse1 réagit un
petit peu comme la CGT dans les années
70 quand on parlait de l'amiante
c'est-à-dire pas de problème il faut pas
le dire il faut préserver l'emploi oui
et quand j'entends un discours
aujourd'hui
de dire il ne faut pas toucher aux
pesticides que le programme Ecophyto
2018 de de baisser l'utilisation des
produits phytosanitaires va mettre en
péril les emplois en France et
l'agriculture c'est un grand mensonge il
y a énormément d'agriculteurs
aujourd'hui qui sont victimes de ces
produits qui sont malades et il faut le
dire c'est pas il y a pas il faut il
faut en parler il y a comme une
agriculture qui sont malades aujourd'hui
il y a pas eu de recensement du moins
ils devaient sortir une étude en 2008
qui est toujours dans les cartons c'est
pareil moi ce que je sais c'est que j'ai
tous les jours des coups de fil des
lettres de gens qui sont malades quand
je suis dans les hôpitaux je vois des
médecins de base qui disent mais on voit
de plus en plus d'agriculteurs qui
arrivent dans nos services pour des
problèmes de néphrologie d'immunité il y
a des ils le voient mais il n'y a pas
d'études pour le dire l'espérance des
agriculteurs de vie était au-dessus de
la moyenne française aujourd'hui elle
est en train de diminuer alors
j'entendais un chercheur le dur qui
disait oui mais ils ont ils fument plus
qu'avant ils sont devenus des citadins
excusez-moi je pense que ça c'est un
raccourci qui est trop vite fait moi je
pense que ça correspond avec
l'utilisation des produits chimiques
qu'on a fait dans les années 80 parce
qu'on sait qu'il faut à peu près 30 ans
70 80 et c'est aujourd'hui qu'on a des
effets sur notre santé le pire quand
même c'est l'omerta du lobby de la
chimie quand même ah oui nous par
exemple on n'a pas le droit de dire ni
le nom ni le fabricants du produit parce
qu'ils vont nous attaquer au tribunal
oui il y a de grandes chances on ne dit
pas en tous les cas il faut pas il faut
pas le dire à chaque fois que j'ai
assisté à une conférence une dernière en
date ils avaient leurs huissier qui
était dans la salle pour écouter c'est
ce que je pouvais dire donc ça montre un
petit peu quelle puissance ils ont mais
je citerai un ami qui est décédé il y a
un an et sur son lit d'hôpital il a
montré au professeur qu'il soignait il
lui a dit vous savez c'est un bon
business quand même parce que je vois
des des noms ici là sur les sur le
goutte-à-goutte sur les perf c'est
exactement quand même les mêmes firmes
qu'ils m'ont fabriqué les désherbants
donc la boucle est bouclée il nous
empoisonne un bout ils nous vendent le
médicament à l'autre chercher l'erreur
mais peut-être que les centres
anti-poison je veux pas parler de
corruption surtout pas mais ne peuvent
pas être jugés partie parce que c'est
laboratoires du fait du manque d'argent
public c'est l'élaboratoires vont
chercher de l'argent sur des groupes qui
sont quand même des choses très
importantes mais peut-être que les
médecins aujourd'hui n'ont pas forcément
c'est indépendance alors finalement
votre maladie est reconnue comme
professionnel et c'est la première fois
dans votre cas donc on a fait le lien
entre un produit phytosanitaire et des
troubles de santé désormais donc vous
combattez vous militez le produit qui
vous a intoxiqué a été interdit aux USA
en 1992 il a été interdit en France en
2007 voilà c'est comme le chlordécone il
était dangereux aux USA en 77 on a
attendu la fin des années 90 pour
l'éliminer en France il faut aussi
savoir que le produit qui me empoisonné
a été retiré du marché par la Commission
européenne parce que trop dangereux pour
l'utilisateur on n'a pas parlé
d'environnement à mon avis
l'environnement ça fait pas de bon on
parlait pas du consommateur mais c'est
un des rares produits qui a été retiré
du marché en disant trop dangereux pour
l'utilisateur est-ce qu'on n'est pas
devant un scandale comparable à celui du
centre contaminé mais pour les
agriculteurs Henri pesera qui est décédé
depuis donc ce professeur m'avait dit je
suis en train de revivre la même chose
qu'avec l'amiante mais je pense que ça
va avoir des conséquences encore plus
grave parce qu'il y aura les
utilisateurs l'environnement le
consommateur et c'est vrai que je crois
qu'il y aura une hécatombe avec ses
produits
en tant que maladie professionnelle pour
le milieu agricole bonjour je rappelle
que vous témoignez dans un film qui sort
le 10 novembre un film de Jean-Paul
Jaude qui s'appelle sévère nous en
parlerons évidemment à ce moment-là
Jean-Louis devrait depuis quelques
années ma fille
Marie-Victoire m'a mis au bio je vais
très bien
vous mangez plus que du bio pratiquement
pratiquement elle a très adepte de ça
elle a considéré que vous n'avait pas
manger trop de viande que les produits
étaient
abîmés par les pesticides par les
nitrates etc moi on vous écoutant je me
posais une question qui fait le lien
avec le débat actuel sur les retraites
je me disais est-ce que ce monsieur fera
partie des gens qui auront des régimes
qui leur permettront de partir plus tôt
à la retraite que montre plutôt que de
se poser la question de savoir s'il y a
des gens qui ont des espérances de vie
plus courtes on ferait peut-être mieux
d'être plus attentif aux conditions de
travail des gens et développer une
véritable médecine du travail préventive
mais si on regarde à l'instant t on va
dire notre espérance de vie est longue
moi j'ai une intoxication aiguë mais
ceux qui ont des intoxications
chroniques il faut 30 ans pour que la
pathologie puisse paraître donc toute
façon si on décide aujourd'hui que ces
gens-là pourront travailler jusqu'à 65
ans parce que leur espérance de vie
étant plus longue je donne rendez-vous
ici dans 20 ans on verra dans quel état
mes collègues seront et là je peux vous
dire que mon avis ça sera pas les mêmes
merci de votre témoignage en tous les
cas merci de m'avoir invité et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu